(bell dinging)
- Hello, everyone, Sal
here, sorry. (laughs)
So this is a very makeshift situation
that we're dealing with.
I've moved locations.
Yesterday, the Internet
connection wasn't so good.
I think it because I was
away from the Wi-Fi router,
so now I'm in my mother-in-law's bedroom
who lives with us.
And it is closer to the Wi-Fi routers.
So hopefully all of this is going to be
a little bit smoother today.
Welcome, I guess you
could say live stream.
That's how people have started calling it,
a home room of sorts just to
get us started on the day.
For those of you who are new,
the goal of this is really
just to be a resource
for parents, for teachers,
and for students.
All of us are trying to navigate
this whole situation
that we find ourselves in
where we have school
closures around the country
and around the world.
I think I saw data yesterday
that there's 900 (distorted speaking)
around the world that
would normally be in school
but who aren't in school right now.
And all of us at Khan Academy,
we realize that we would
have never foreseen
this type of a situation, but we exist
to help out a situation like this.
All of our entire team at Khan Academy,
I really wanna thank everyone
on Khan Academy's team
and all of the supporters of Khan Academy
and our volunteers and
our teacher ambassadors
for really stepping up
over the last few days.
I've been mentioning this every day,
but some of the core resources
that we've been putting out,
other than doing this daily live stream,
or home room, if you will,
we've been putting out teacher webinars
to help teachers get signed up.
We've been seeing record number
of registrations of teachers.
It looks like some might
even be a factor of 10.
At least that's what
one of my team members
told me earlier this morning.
We're seeing a record number
of registration of parents
who are running parent webinars
to help parents get set up.
Over the weekend, we realized that
we have a lot of resources at Khan Academy
that cover all of the
major subjects and grades,
but parents and teachers
who are now looking
to virtualize need to know,
well, how do I structure the
day so it feels like school?
And obviously, this is
a substitute for it,
and this is a very suboptimal situation.
We released schedules that
work for students as young
as pre-K going into kindergarten,
first, second grade.
Then we have a schedule
for elementary age,
schedule for middle and high school,
and then schedule for later high school
across subjects and grades so that people
know how to structure their day.
And it's not just do this
thing on Khan Academy
or that thing on Khan Academy.
There are breaks scheduled in.
There's even some resources we, or recess,
one of my family friends immediately
when she saw that it had
Yoga with Adriene on it,
and Just Dance, she's, those are two
of my favorite exercise activities
when it's a rainy day
and I can't go outside.
So yes, I had a little bit
of editorial influence,
but those are resources for all of you.
We're doing this live stream.
Expect over the coming days and weeks
to see more live streams
that maybe spawn off of this.
We're exploring ways to provide
teachers and students and
parents more supports.
One idea that we've talked about,
and I've talked about this yesterday,
is as you go through those schedules
of leveraging Khan Academy
and other resources,
if teachers could set up a webinar
or video conferencing for their students,
that way the students could log in
while they're obviously
working on Khan Academy math
or biology, and then ask questions,
students could also
self-organize around that.
And if folks are still
just getting off the ground
and parents could also.
The other thing I really wanna
emphasize for everyone is
don't stress out about the situation.
We're really just at the beginning
of a situation that's
very new to all of us.
And so, even if it takes several days
going into next week to
get everyone into a rhythm,
that's completely understandable.
In my house, we have had situation.
I had to hush my children outside
as they were screaming
over, fighting over a chair
for eating breakfast.
This is an interesting
situation for all of us.
And we just saw news last night,
we've been talking about
something like this,
if you just look at the,
what's been happening
in other countries and when
you might hit peak virus
or peak infection, it
looks like it's going to be
more than just a few weeks.
Several school districts, the
team tells me I think Kansas,
let me make sure I'm getting that right,
announced, yeah, it says
Kansas is the first state
to close schools for the
rest of the academic year.
We have about 2 1/2 months
in the academic year,
and so that probably will be
extended for a lot of folks.
I think all of us need to figure out
how do we work together to make sure
that everyone keeps learning,
not just through the rest
of the academic year, but then we can
leverage summer as well
to keep that learning
so that as we go into
the new school year where
hopefully everything is fine by then,
everyone is ready and capable to engage.
And if, for whatever reason,
this whole situation comes back,
we know how to switch between
these modalities quite fast.
Let me look at some
questions that are here.
One question was, are we able
to meet increased demands,
or are we seeing any increased demands?
What the team at Khan Academy has told me,
on Monday we saw a 50% increase in traffic
from the Monday previous,
and it looks like Tuesday,
yesterday, was even higher than Monday.
And so we're still looking at
the data, but it looks like
there's a pretty dramatic
increase in demand.
And obviously, there's an increased demand
for this type of thing, for us to be able
to help people navigate the entire crisis.
I wanna make a huge shout out,
for those of you who haven't seen it,
there was a press release last night,
Bank of America I wanna
thank operation to step up.
We've had a long standing
relationship with Bank of America.
They've been the main partner
for our financial literacy content,
for our career content
over the past seven years,
and the reason why Khan Academy has even
been able to step up in this crisis
is because of many years of support
from folks like Bank of America.
But as soon as Thursday
and Friday of last week,
they saw that this is going to be
a bit of a situation
around the school closures.
They immediately saw us as
a really instrumental part
of this, and they called us up and said,
what can we do to help?
We wanna make sure that America
and the world can keep learning.
And over the weekend,
they've provided resources
for Khan Academy so that we
could keep our servers up,
so we can do this type of live stream.
We're calling it a national,
or international home room.
They've provided, they're
gonna help provide awareness
so that parents, teachers, students
around the country who might not be aware
of Khan Academy or the
resources we're providing
over this, I guess you could
call it social distancing,
that we're able to provide
more of those resources
that we have the aperture to think bigger
about how we can solve things.
And they also have a lot
of really good partnerships
with other nonprofits, school districts,
solve parts of the situation
because Khan Academy is a part of it.
We have, obviously we
can do things online.
We have all of this content,
all of this software,
but above and beyond that,
we wanna look to partner with folks
to ensure that all students
can have access to things
like Internet right now.
That's valuable not just for Khan Academy
but it's also, I think important
in this time of social distancing
to be able to have some social interaction
that's not traditional social media,
but you can also interact with
people and things like that.
Thank you so much for Bank of America
for being in record time, stepping up
to support Khan Academy
so that we can support
so many others and helping
the support directly.
I'd love to answer y'all's questions.
Let's see, I can look at
this stream down here,
and I can see what the
team is surfacing to me.
There is one question,
let's see, how do I figure out
what my child should be learning?
There's a couple of ways
to think about this.
I actually had a really
great conversation.
Some of you might have seen
the video with Tim Vandenberg,
who is grade math teacher
in Hesperia, California.
I also learned yesterday,
he's the number two
Monopoly player in the
country or the world.
There's a documentary
about him apparently.
So he's an impressive guy
all around. (laughing)
And I always thought
Monopoly was mostly luck,
but I was like, "Can you
always beat me in Monopoly?"
He was like, "Yes, I will
pretty much always beat you."
And then he said, "My sixth graders
"will beat you at Monopoly."
So he knows what he's doing in Monopoly.
And frankly, if we can figure out a way
to bring in remote guests
on this live stream,
I would love to bring Tim in.
But the reason why I brought up Tim
is he has some really great ways
to work with students, gaps
in their knowledge because
there's two views.
One view is, say, okay, we're about 3/4
through the school year, so therefore,
maybe we should be exactly 3/4
through whatever grade level
your child is working on.
And there's a lot of truth to that.
What Tim Vandenberg has seen is that
a lot of his students, as they've gone
at a fixed pace for all students,
they might get a B in one concept,
so they have a 10% gap,
a C in another concept,
they have a 20% gap, and
those gaps keep accumulating.
And that's why when he
gets them in sixth grade,
oftentimes they have trouble engaging
in that grade level material.
And so what he does is he
has all of his students,
these are sixth graders,
start at kindergarten
on Khan Academy, and do our,
or actually our Early Learning
section on Khan Academy
and our Arithmetic
section on Khan Academy,
and our third grade.
Those are the three he
says he has them focus on.
And then simultaneously,
he also tries to get them
to complete unit by unit at sixth grade
so they're able to be on grade level
and make sure they have
all their gaps filled.
And at his school, in his
school, 90% of the students
that come to him are
well below grade level.
So it's super important for him.
But what he finds is is
by allowing some time
for the students to remediate
or fill in those gaps,
they're more likely to
really master the concepts
at the grade level as well.
This is just a long-winded way of saying,
you should absolutely
talk to your student,
or if you are the student, think about
where you are in the year.
You can start on those
units on Khan Academy,
but given that we have
more flexibility right now
given your school day is really defined
by you and your parents and your teachers,
that you could especially in math,
you could spend a little bit extra time
where you can do things
at your grade level
or that at your own time
and pace on Khan Academy.
So if you're a sixth grader,
work on the sixth grade math.
You could take the Course Challenge.
The Course Challenge will take
you about 30 or 40 minutes,
but it'll accelerate the
things that you already know,
and then the things you're
having difficulty with,
you can go to those units,
and then you can take the unit test there.
And then on those unit
tests, when you take those,
you can learn what skills
you might need help on.
And if you do that in sixth grade,
and then it wouldn't be a bad idea
to set some other time, maybe
another half an hour a day,
where you start with early
math on Khan Academy,
go into the arithmetic,
go into third grade
to really make sure you have your basics.
You can use things like
the Course Challenges
and Unit Tests and the Mastery Challenges
to accelerate through it.
So it's not going to
take you a lot of time
if you already know all of the materials.
Let me look at other courses.
Another thing about the schedule,
another like what to
work on during the year,
I think it's important to realize,
this is for parents as well,
that if you the student or you the parent,
as long as the student can
focus on the foundations
and really master it.
So what I've been telling
the press lately is
we have these schedules that can fill up
most of what would be the
traditional school hours,
but if you at least do two hours a day,
an hour of reading, an hour of math,
that will get your basics.
Those skills won't atrophy.
Your reading comprehension will keep up,
and your math skills won't go away.
But ideally, you're able
to look at a schedule
like what we've published
and modify it to your own needs obviously
and hopefully make use and
give us feedback on that.
Questions.
"Is it okay if I put up a pic of you?
"Students want to know how you look."
I don't think I could stop
you from doing that. (laughs)
They might be disappointed when they see
what I really look like,
but I'll defer to you.
You're the educator,
if that's a good idea.
Okay, Chandler Pak, Park, sorry,
Chandler Park asks, "Would there be
"live academic classes on Khan Academy?
"I saw some live SAT math
classes on YouTube in the past,
"and I was wondering if this
is something that is going
"to be something especially
because of COVID-19."
Chandler, we are exploring
doing things like that.
You're exactly right.
In the past, for things like SAT and AP,
webinars, live streams, and our team
is exploring how we can do that.
I also want folks who create
video conferencing software,
are there ways to get people
into video conferencing groups
so that they can also help each other?
So we can do these larger
scale live streams,
whether it's from me or other teachers
or content creators, and
then it would also be great
if we could find ways for folks
to connect with each other
and answer each other's questions.
Simple answer is yes.
The plan is there.
Hopefully you'll start
seeing some of that stuff
by next week or even at
the end of this week.
Okay, let's see.
"It says, on Facebook,
we saw a lot of comments
"about pursuing passions and hobbies.
"Is that in the schedule?
"How important is that?"
This is, passions and hobbies
are a super important thing.
And in some ways, you view this situation
we find ourselves in as glass half full.
I think especially as
you get into high school,
a lot of students, and
if you are a student,
I'll talk to you, a lot of you are,
would traditionally have
a lot on your plate.
You're taking six classes.
You're doing all these
extracurricular activities.
You're taking the SAT.
You're studying for AP tests.
You're applying to college.
It can be pretty stressful.
Now, all of a sudden, a
lot of that is cleared out.
And so I think this is
a really powerful time
for you to keep on your academics,
and that's where we've
really gotta help you.
And also, think, you have
time to pursue your passions.
It might be creating videos.
It might be writing.
It might be software.
It might be dance.
And I think creativity is oftentimes
the byproduct of boredom.
So if you have a little bit
of time on your hands now,
really think about what motivates you.
And this whole crisis that we're
all going through together,
there's a lot of new problems
that I think need to be solved,
and so if you're a student,
think about how you would
solve those problems.
Are there new types of
things you can invent
that will lower the spread of the virus
or that can help people?
Are there volunteer
efforts that you can do
even while people are social distanced
to make sure that maybe members
of your community who
might be living alone,
might not have as much support,
that they are feeling a
connection with other people
or that they feel supported or people
can help them with their
groceries and things like that?
There's things we have to
think about with the economy.
I'm very fortunate.
I'm continuing to get my salary
because I can do my work remotely.
There's a lot of folks that now
that there's this social
distancing in place,
California where I live is now
in full stay in place orders,
there's a lot of people who aren't able
to make their living right now.
Are there creative ideas to how we help
some of those folks?
Yeah, I think this is a
great time for your passions,
and you can almost, you
could really view this
as a bit of a opportunity.
See, other questions, I keep
having to re-log, let's see.
So Sonya Taburg says, "Sal, you talk
"about eliminating the
Swiss cheese analogy
"of math education, lots of
holes in one's understanding.
"Once learners gain mastery
of certain math concepts,
"is there a way of enlarging the knowledge
"and unlocking more
practical tasks or challenges
"or math projects?
"It'd be cool if embedded in the site
"were Easter egg-like challenges
"for kids to unlock thoughts."
Well, Sonya, what you're describing
is something we would love to do.
And I hope we can do over time.
And I was talking about Tim Vandenberg,
and I talked about his
methodology he uses,
but he's been seeing incredible results
where pretty much every one of his,
he starts the year 90% of his students
aren't at grade level.
He sees pretty much year where 90%
of his students are at
grade level or above
by the end of the year by making sure
that his students can fill
in their Swiss cheese gaps.
And I'll ask the team to put the link
to the Tim Vandenberg video,
or actually webinar that we
had below in our description
or in our live stream some place
because not only is it
inspiring for teachers
to see what Tim's done, I think it can be
very inspiring for parents to say, oh,
well, now we have an opportunity.
We can do this at home,
leveraging Khan Academy.
It's also hopefully inspiring for students
to say, oh, maybe this is why
I've been having trouble in algebra.
It's not because I'm not bright.
It's not because algebra's difficult.
It's because I had all
these gaps accumulating.
What Tim says even sixth
graders, seventh graders,
you start them on that early math,
third grade math, arithmetic,
they almost always discover,
even the ones that are A or B students,
some of the ones who are
performing at grade level,
they discover that they had
some gaps with mathematics.
And so let's see.
Let's see, Michael Toscano says,
"It's probably old at this point,
"but this time the video really
puts the home in home room!"
(laughs) Yes, you're right!
This is a literally a room in my home.
It is home room, that is correct.
(distorted speaking) Stuff
going on at her work.
There, he doesn't get exposed somehow
and obviously I have three kids,
and I have to say, the older two,
our school is doing engage in his work.
Again, it's interesting times.
I definitely empathize.
And it's one of these times
where it's a lot of
gratitude and thankful.
It makes you appreciate a
lot of the small things.
I went to the grocery store
this morning at 6:00 AM,
which is when it opened.
I figured, that might be the best time.
But you can imagine it was already
an interesting place to be.
But I felt fortunate
to even be able to go.
Let's see, other questions.
"Is Khan Academy," this
is from Nolan Fisherman,
"is Khan Academy enough
to study for the AP exam?"
What is other questions that people have?
Let's see, just a lot of nice people.
Apparently I am lagging.
I'm sorry.
Give me feedback.
This is closer to my
Wi-Fi router, we'll see.
Let's see, "do you,"
so someone says, "do you think scientists
"will find a cure for COVID-19?
"If so, when do you think we'll find it?"
I'm not an epidemiologist.
I'm not an virologist.
So take all of this with a grain of salt,
but I've taught some of
the things on viruses
and things on Khan Academy.
Look, I don't think any of us really know,
including many of the
experts at this point.
We can only hope.
There's some early reports
of doctors using cocktails
of existing drugs
that have been used for other things,
like malaria or AIDS that
might have some promise to it.
Who knows?
It's just, we're getting
such distorted reports
from different parts of the world
with very different mortality
rates and infection rates,
and obviously the testing is a big issue.
The number one thing all of us can do
is minimize contact with
physical contact right now
to try to stay with your family.
I'm really glad that California
where I live decided to
make the hard decision
of doing the stay in place order.
It's hard.
Everyone has to be in their house.
They are allowing that you can go outside
if you wanna go for a run, but even then,
they say make sure you
keep distances from people.
But this is the kind of
action you need to do,
and in any type of
epidemiological response,
if you do the right thing,
it will look like you are overly cautious.
But if you aren't overly cautious,
then you see these things
grow exponentially,
and then it's very hard to stop.
And the United States, we are
in an unfortunate situation
where the testing isn't
where it needs to be,
and so I posted a video
that the likely cases
are far higher, are likely far higher,
in fact, almost for sure, are far higher
than the reported cases.
So it's very prudent that in our area,
the seven counties for
seven million people
they did the stay in place order.
I think that will be useful for much
of the rest of the world.
Obviously, it has economic implications,
et cetera, et cetera.
But it's much better to
nip things in the bud,
and it might be a little bit
past the bud stage right now.
We will see.
We're all through this together.
This is really interesting time.
It's a great time to learn
about what a virus is,
what DNA is, what RNA
is, listen to the news,
learn a lot about how the economy works
'cause people are realizing,
okay, there's certain roles where people
are able to have income,
but there's other parts
of our economy where
people already didn't have
a lot of money, but they're
getting hourly paychecks.
Now the restaurants in our area,
all of the restaurants are
closed except for takeout.
How are the owners gonna
have money to pay them?
And if they don't have money, how are they
going to be able to even
get the basic necessities
they need or pay rent?
There's all sorts of interesting ideas
that people are starting to float
on how to get everyone through this.
But I've been proud just
to see how most people
have been acting in the
collective interest,
which I think is really, really powerful.
Maybe time for a few more questions.
I started late.
And I really enjoy this.
This is almost a little
bit for my sanity as well.
It feels really nice to feel
even virtually connected
with all of you 'cause I
am also socially distanced.
Let's see, let's see, other,
let's see, let's see
other, other questions.
Someone said, "Will you get
into the engineering field?"
We have some contact on
electrical engineering
on Khan Academy.
In the near term, we
probably won't go deep
into the engineering field, but long term,
I hope one day we can
do some of the basics
of some of the engineering fields.
Let's see, other, other,
other, someone said,
oh, let's see, other
questions people are asking.
"Any plans on expanding Khan Academy
"higher studies like engineering?"
A lot of people want engineering.
Let's see other questions.
I'll go to see what the team
might have surfaced as well.
There are a lot of comments coming in
on social media as well.
Anna Murray asked, "Do you things
"for early learning before first grade?"
And Khan Academy Kids, it's
available on Android and on iOS.
It's free.
Go download it.
What you'll see is when you see most apps
for especially that age
group, they just do one thing.
This app has a little bit
of a universe inside of it.
It has over 100 books,
has hundreds of videos,
and they're interactive videos
where there'll be a song and a dance.
And then they'll stop,
and they'll ask your child
or your student to do something.
It's appropriate for students
as early as age three.
In fact, I would say even
potentially for age two.
For that age group, it's always best
to be able to do it next to
or on the lap of a loved one,
a parent, an uncle, aunt, a
grandparent, older sibling.
But if they're able to do 20 minutes,
30 minutes a day, I think
they'll really enjoy it.
And we've seen some promising
efficacy studies around it,
and it'll get them, it
starts with letters,
numbers, colors, social,
emotional learning,
but it goes all the way through
the Head Start Standards,
the Kindergarten Common Core Standards,
and the First Grade Common Core Standards.
If you start your child on
it, start in age three, say,
it has plenty of runway for them
that it can keep them busy for a while.
And it adapts to them
based on what they know
and what they don't know, so
highly, highly encourage that.
That's why we created Khan Academy Kids.
We've seen downloads go up.
Last I heard from our team,
fivefold from what they typically are.
Hopefully, people are making...
One foot in front, they are
representing other companies.